welcome to c-span tues afterwards my
name is Ezra Klein from the Washington
Post I'm here with a Steven Levitt and
Stephen Dubner to talk about their hit
new book superfreakonomics so thank you
both for being with us here today thanks
Ezra thank you so to begin tell me a bit
about how we got to freakonomics you you
have up in one of the early chapters a
bit about the name and this is one of
the sort of big brands and economic
publishing now but but it almost didn't
happen what were the other names oh
they're so bad that's embarrassing so
the worst turner was a near a vision you
like you like like it today's girl I'll
I've always a tearing that was bad even
though it was my idea the idea was ear a
vision irae being economics as being the
special power to look through and
there'd have to be some kind of
character with a big cake yeah is bad
but my favorite that was bad but it was
a it was a great bad one was so we
should say levites sister Linda joins
came up with freakonomics and it was
great because we had this book that was
kind of about nothing everything and
nothing so it was hard to name it
properly so it needed a kind of
nonsensical name but her other great
terrible name was Bend It Like Veblen
which I think you have to acknowledge is
so bad but it might be the best thing
ever but alas we didn't choose it it
would be fun watching people in the
future try to try to make sense or in
the present actually but yes but sighs
you said it's a book of it it's a bit
about nothing a bit about everything and
so what's the project what's what's the
project of freakonomics I don't know if
there's a project exactly I think I've
spent a lifetime studying economics in
my own way using the tools of economics
like models and like thinking about
incentives and look using data to figure
out the difference between correlation
and causality but applied to a different
set of questions right the first book
looked at crack selling gangs have
looked at cheating sumo wrestlers
cheating teachers whether your name
mattered it a set of topics that no
self-respecting economist would ever
take on but you have a different kind of
economist I don't I don't know anything
about the macroeconomy I don't know
anything about financial crisis but you
know but I kept myself busy studying
these topics and somehow some way they
turned out to be interesting to everyday
people and before we dive into some of
the actual studies in here two things
for i think that the listeners would be
helpful one is a difference as he said
you're not a macro economy
micro economist so a quick word on the
difference there and also about the
natural experiments which are known for
was a bit different I think then how
people normally think of of economic
research being conducted absolutely so
economics is divided the two big camps
macroeconomics and microeconomics
backward comment macroeconomics is what
most people think of when they think of
economics it's about interest rates it's
about GDP recessions and macroeconomics
is hard right the economic system is
complex how millions and pour billions
of individual behaviors aggregate up
into an economy is a question that
really we haven't had all that much luck
making sense of as sort of a you know
made clear by some of the recent going
ons now microeconomics is about
individual behavior it's a way of saying
can I predict what you are going to do
when I put you in a situation or maybe
even easier looking back why did people
act the way they did and so that that is
microeconomics the kind of thing I do
any topic I describe almost every one of
them is about individuals or maybe firms
at the biggest and how they make their
choices okay now you brought up this
idea of natural experiments okay which I
actually for for a broader audience I'd
like to call it accidental experiments
but let me take a step back even from
that into methodology so that the
cornerstone of the scientific method is
the randomized experiment right when we
decide whether the FDA should approve a
particular drug we go and when
randomized experiments we see whether
how the drug works in a double-blind
experiment relative to a placebo and we
were able to just compare the people got
treated to the people who weren't they
were randomized so the difference
between the outcomes tells us whether or
not that drug works okay as an economist
as much as I would love to carry out
randomized experiments it's not always
possible so for instance we talk in the
book about how you know I'd love to know
one of the questions I wanted always do
prisons reduce crime but it's not like
the NSF is going to allow me to go out
and run a randomized experiment where I
lock up a bunch of people in one state
and random and I randomly release a
bunch of people in another state and
then see what happens right so so in
that kind of a world a complex where
we're living economists have had to use
what I call accidental experiments to
figure out the answer so in other words
i look for quirks where you know
something like a law change or like so
if you want to talk about abortion and
crime so i have it
very controversial theory about how
abortion legalization of abortion in the
1970s reduced crime in the 1990s okay so
there it's really not a random
experiment but after abortion became
legal in some states very easy given
boards in other states whose very hard
so you can compare twenty years later
what happened in the states were is easy
to get an abortion to those states where
it was hard to get an abortion that's
what we would call an accidental
experiment and its really kind of the
new wave of micro economic research is
to not just look for pure correlations
but to go deeper to try to find evidence
of these sort of these experiment to the
Kwazii experiment so you try to think
what can I do that close close to
replicating scientific experiment as
possible and now even economists are
getting into running randomized
experiments more so one my colleagues
John list we talk about a lot in
superfreakonomics is really at the
cutting edge of field experiments so not
going into the lab with college students
and asking them to do things they're not
used to but really going out into
real-world settings when people don't
know they're being watched and trying to
learn from their behavior where you
truly do random us and how do you
separate this from psychology from from
sociology from other disciplines right i
mean the economics in case she gets
accused of i think with people call
economic imperialism where you folks
might even get to start plant your flag
and what other folks consider their
discipline so you know how is this
different from psychology how did the
techniques differ cheb you listen to
your psychologist on how people act oh
probably involve i think a little both i
mean i think that psychologists and ask
different questions right so with an
economist a psychologist has the same
question then the methods we're using
when you're going to randomized
experiment so would be similar although
psychologists rarely if ever venture out
of the lab because have decided that the
lab is the perfect kind of sterile
environment in which you can learn
everything you can and you have complete
control economists have really John list
and myself in particular have been much
more critical of the lab because it is
an artificial environment and one of the
things that psychologists know well is
that depending on how you run an
experiment you can get a college student
to do just about anything right and so
for the questions that psychologists are
interested it's often about motivations
they're trying to they're almost more
interested in how you manipulate people
into doing things than in extrapolating
outside the lab to how people will
behave in the real
really I think that's an important
distinction economists tend to be
interested in will this tax do what we
think it will and psychologists tend to
be interested in how will people feel
about the tax and and so you know in
general a lot of the topics I study do
overlap or sociology there's
sociological in nature but I asked them
in a very different way than
sociologists do now sometimes I team up
with sociologists like sudhir venkatesh
when I work on gangs and my work on
prostitution and then we try to bring
both pieces of it but if you ask a
sociologist they won't confuse my work
with sociology because I very much stick
to using the economic tools the same
tools that economists have used for
hundreds of years to try to study
markets and you know and and in prices
and quantities I've taken out to study
questions like you know does education
work or you know ah does it work Eddie
case you know the returns to education
are huge I mean it's amazing i manage
say an education system perfect but if
you look at people who get more
education and in really at the causal
effect of getting an extra year The
Economist say an extra year of education
is worth about eight percent to your
lifetime learning so it's a really good
return now eventually get too much
education it starts to hurt to get a PhD
in the more years you get what you pay
your wages actually start to go down but
but you're not just buying you know when
you get a PhD you're buying a
comfortable life like the one I live
where you get that you know do whatever
you want but so look I need a lot to fix
an education and working on it as well
but but by and large and we have it we
do have not such a bad agenda world
where we're very much are importers of
people coming in to buy are you know
people want to buy our educational
system at the higher level so I think we
have a lot to be proud of it's
nonetheless and so the other blend of
disciplines is in the book comes on your
side as a reporter and so the book ends
it ends up sort of being interesting
we're sort of one chapter will be about
a very deep data set and a no chapter
will be you know what I sorta more
record what I recognize being reporters
more traditional reporting a long
interview with the source you know going
out into the field going to events and
watching up people react and you know
trying to take a sort of the pulse of a
cultural moment or an intellectual
moment here and so how do those work
together I mean they are very different
disciplines and they are so
empirically though I love my job and I
meant like yours where where to sort of
different level of raya than than other
Stephen if you notice the divide that
well that's bad a bad sign on our behalf
because they're meant to really
shouldn't I don't mean to trash us
entirely but we do try to marry them you
know maybe you're more perceptive than
the average reader because that's the
kind of work you do a lot of people when
they're reading about even some of the
empirical stuff they don't really think
of it as research versus reporting and
when they think about a kind of a
character narrative they might may not
think about that as research versus
reporting or versus empirical but yeah
we try to basically create a hybrid of a
few different things empirical research
that may have any of five or ten
different you know kind of degrees of
gravity and degrees of difficulty and so
on they may be broad topics they may be
narrow topics then we also write about
you know one thing that we decide from
the outset is in order to bring these
empirical in order to bring these
academic papers alive you want to read
about the people who are involved in
them and sometimes the people are
involved in them are the people who
gather the data so Leavitt works with a
lot of data but that doesn't mean he
goes and generates it or gathers it by
himself usually often so for instance
this fellow sudhir venkatesh who Steve
Levitt mentioned a while ago to me as a
writer who's writing about topics that
are empirically arrived that there's a
great value in meeting the character and
it's not just for color it's for
understanding kind of the shape of the
project the motivation and so on then
there are some pieces in
superfreakonomics that are there
different from what was in the first
book certainly the first book was I
don't know maybe eighty percent ninety
percent based on Levites researcher done
in collaboration with co-authors this
one maybe fifty sixty some people think
less because we usually keep Leavitt out
as the coop we tell the stories of the
co-authors the John lists the sudhir
venkatesh the Craig feed all these other
people so his hand was very heavily
involved in it but we did also we were
making different kinds of arguments in
superfreakonomics we were
no whether we tried to engage more
mainstream topics or whether it just
came out of our interest of of these
topics so when you look at global
warming or terrorism or education and
health care while there's a lot of
empirical stuff in there we felt it was
really valuable to build build within
build that within a story where there's
a narrative as well so yeah I think it
was less trying to engage in these more
political topics or I don't believe more
hot topics current topics I think was
just the fact that after the first book
a lot of doors opened up all right so if
I wanted to study terrorism and I gonna
knocked on the door of a British bank
and they said hey you've never heard of
me but I'm an academic and I really want
to you know work with you to find
terrorists they what it just laughed at
me they would have sent me away but
after the book people were much more
willing to to open up with data and with
stories and so I think that Deb really
I'm it was a one of the benefits of the
first book was that when you know when I
first started I thought well this is
this is going to be really a substitute
for doing academic research i'm going to
end up taking a lot of time away from my
research and to write a pop of the book
but but i weighed the trade-offs like
any economist would and i said okay
maybe i'll do it anyway i was really
wrong i mean we talked a lot about
unintended consequence one of the
unintended consequences writing a
best-selling book we said it was
actually complimented my research it
allowed me to do things that I never
could have done otherwise right there's
a lot of research that levites been
doing in the last you know three four
five five years four and a half years
since freakonomics came out that's
really good that that is good or a real
will yield really good academic research
that was totally uninteresting for a
book like this you know a lot of it kind
of having do with firms and pricing and
strategy that you know if we want to
write a business book would be very very
good for that and you we could write
about case studies we could write about
phenomenally interesting mistakes that
firms have made the good things that
come out of that but there's a lot of
research that didn't work for the book
and then there are a lot of there's a
lot of kind of storytelling that we felt
worked for the book that would augment
the empirical research and so there's
also a danger to this right there what
you both have a certain tool kits right
your-your-your very well known for being
able to apply with with great skill this
natural experiment or accidental
experiment toolkit along with the
econometrics and so
elements of the profession in this
reporter you know there's a certain tool
kit there but what a lot of people would
say and one of the criticisms of the
book is it you're not experts in all
these subjects not if you're a terrorism
expert even within the context of these
disciplines or our economist who focus
in one you know energy economists or
healthcare economists but that you sort
of do take on a lot of these large
topics and not only that but come to
conclusions oftentimes quite opposed to
the conventional wisdom of the expert
community so how do you weigh that right
how AR you so how do you develop the
confidence to say these people been
studying for so long we're actually
wrong on it but be you know what are the
dangerous how do you make sure you're
not being entranced by a good salesman
or buy a paper that as you say would
work for the book where others don't yes
I I think a lot of it comes down to the
approach that take which is which is
based on data and in kind of strips away
a lot of the issues of ethics and
morality I mean a lot of studying a
question a lot of the subtleties of
questions come down to kind of right or
right versus wrong and rarely rarely are
we in the business of right versus wrong
so let's take I don't know so let's take
one of the controversial subjects which
you could say I'm not an expert in in
the sense that I haven't spent my life
studying it which is car seats for the
seat belts all right so so what did i do
though I wouldn't I got every publicly
available data set I could get my hands
on and I analyzed them in the way that I
know how to analyze data sets and
whether you look at the data in simple
ways or look at the data in complex ways
you just don't see a very big difference
in the effectiveness of child car seats
relative to adult seat belt in saving
the lives of young children to
children's to children to a note now you
deceive some benefits some relatively
minor benefits of car seats in terms of
injuries relative to see those now both
car seats and seat belts are a world
better than not being restrained at all
okay so in some sense I'm not an expert
in this area but I have access through
the data and I look at it I do what I
know how to do and I find it and you
know on top of that Steve and I went out
and did some crash tests we actually pay
it out of our pocket to do some crash
tests because we couldn't find any
evidence in the literature about how
crash test dummies of young children
size did when you when you put them
adult seatbelts
and so I mean I think a lot of times
what we talked about experts to to kind
of get up to speed certainly within the
economic leaders you get up to speed in
an area for somebody like me it just
doesn't take that long right I mean it
takes you know I can read the literature
literature isn't that large usually
there are a lot of sources got much
easier to learn about the literature now
than it used to be and you know it's
it's more what's harder than doing the
academic work is maybe coming up with
some you know a brilliant public policy
plan that that will take into account
all of the special interests all the
political realities what you can and
can't do but that's not really our thing
I mean I thing I think is that is that
is to take ideas to get people thinking
to challenge conventional wisdom where
it deserves to be challenged and in so
in many ways it's better to be an
outsider it's almost impossible to tell
John to conventional wisdom from the
inside out because yeah I think you just
lose the perspective that comes with
distance and newness to a subject when
you're when you're part of it like for
me now I've studied crime for a decade
he's really hard for me to have original
thoughts on crime that aren't heavily
weighed you know heavily influenced by
what I've studied so it'll be someone
new who comes along has a next big
breakthrough on crime I think that's an
interesting point actually right because
so so you actually feel that having been
very deeply involved in crime you've
stopped sort of having new ways to look
at it but does that when you as you say
you sort of continue studying crime so
suddenly seem to believe you can still
make progress on it so do you believe
you stopped having newest look at it
because you've learned more and actually
the new ways are wrong then in fact the
conventional wisdom is the consensus of
an expert community because it's right
and and the new breakfast will be done
by a fresh pair of eyes are going to be
accurate or you know it doesn't doesn't
that have a sort of weird set of
implications for the other pieces of
your answer there but no I I its people
always have different opinions so do i
think that the research i've done on
crime is right yeah i think it's been
good i think it's been helpful did I
bring new perspectives to crime that
criminologist didn't have our other it
comes to them definitely all right now I
mean I've pored over the evidence in a
ways that have really set my thinking I
believe things now and you know and it
partly it's just I had the ideas that I
have right
so you it new people will come did and
they might have better ideas different
ideas so for instance i'm trying to
think about how to stop violence in the
Chicago Public Schools and I know a lot
about stopping violence and I think
through the entire checklist of all the
things that I think could possibly work
that are politically viable that we can
actually do that will stop violence or
less than in the air and I think we
don't have anything I can't think one
thing on the table so I even got the
point where I ask the blog readers alike
i don't know maybe the blog readers have
some ideas about it i mean it's hard and
but i could imagine uh you know it just
went up today it would leverage my over
there were 70 80 comments I don't know
it's it's hard I mean if you're easy you
know it would but so that's where if you
never know where the next great idea is
going to come from um and I don't want
to make it sound like I don't think
great ideas ever come from people within
an area obviously it helps to know the
institutional details to do it I do
think that oftentimes some of the really
great ideas come from the outside in so
one of the early places in the book were
sort of scratch my I thought huh you
know I wonder if this is really this is
really accurate came in the very first
vignette it's about drunk driving and
drunk walking and you make the point
that actually if you look at the data if
you compare miles driven drunk and miles
walk drunk people died a much higher
rate when they're walking drunk and you
know this actually sort of used to
illustrate in the beginning of the book
the actual perspective of the book that
you know a lot of these things that you
think to be a settled question are in
fact not settled at all but I was really
struck by a move you guys made a
methodological move which I'm sure
focusing audience are ecstatic to hear
that word real early on and I'm going to
read it here because I want to make sure
I get it right but say said that um you
began by saying surveys show that one
out of every 140 miles driven is driven
drunk so every time people drive on 240
million miles or 140 road was that our
language that doesn't sound right
servation so data showed you miss survey
on miles trim I don't think so that was
an empirical that's tricky yeah that's a
hard enough sorry those numbers those
numbers are ya hey so I'm not
questioning that that's fine okay so one
out of every hundred and forty miles is
driven drunk which i think is a number
to actually be surprising to a lot of
folks yeah but then you said that um
then quote there are some two hundred
thirty-seven million Americans 16 and
older all told that's 43 billion miles
walked each year by people of driving
age if we assume that one at every 140
of those miles or watching so if we
assume same number of miles driven drunk
or walk drunk same percentage then
that's 307 million miles walk drunk and
that's much more dangerous and so you
even say elsewhere in the book friends
don't let friends walk drunk what I
found striking about this is it seemed
that that assumption packed a lot in
right so among other things are packed
in the idea that in fact it is the same
so when I go if I go out to a bar and
decide I'm going to not take my car
today because I'm going to get drunk
that would imply actually give them
substituting miles walked for miles
driven that miles walk were actually
going to be a higher proportion so not
one out of 140 but say one out of 120 or
one out of 100 then there's this
question about the same type of miles
right rural and urban or are they as
drunk miles right and maybe the people
drive more often when they have three
glasses of beer but they're actually a
little bit over well when you know
you're sort of frat buddy you can't see
anymore you take his keys away and the I
guess the question I want to ask you on
this is that this seemed like sort of a
lot of leaps of logic and it wouldn't
have particularly you know struck my
caught my eye except for the topic in
this topic people were going to look at
this you know people maybe don't know
stats that well and say a celebrated
economist and a respected report are
saying I should drive home drunk tonight
well that's so for me first of all that
if you think that then you're not
reading the book carefully because we
explicitly and implicitly state that the
solution to the problem is not to drive
instead the solution the problem is to
do something else call a taxi whatever
but anyway i'll let you because so the
last thing in I'm not even comfortable
you phrasing the question like that
because if anybody catches that part of
the question they're going to say what
and make an assumption but you do have
friends don't let friends walk truck
well yeah that's right but it's not as
but I don't think we want it yeah so
let's make this all let's take this go
ahead so let's start by my own research
that we cite in in the beginning of that
vignette says that drunk driving is 13
times more dangerous than driving self
okay and that's a published paper and
it's consistently on the high end of
tail so like we're no way condoning
driving drunk but I think what is
implicit in your
what other who will seem to feel as well
is it somehow by saying that there's
something even worse than driving drunk
that we are condoning it I mean but it
seems strange me right if I told you
that you know if you were if you had a
political interest group in education
group that went around telling people
not to poke their eyes out with scissors
and then I came along and said well you
know it's also really bad to poke your
eye out with a butcher knife I mean I
can't see that you would get upset say
well now you're just condoning people
poking out with scissors well I guess I
mean so so so I think on that point so I
don't go ahead maybe I can tell you that
right so if somebody's leaving a bar a
friend's party there actually aren't a
whole ton of options right it is it most
people don't poke their eyes out with
scissors or the hot poker and so when
you say you shouldn't do either thing
they say okay well maybe I'll play a
video game instead but people every day
I mean the reason there's so much
controversial is top because people have
to make this decision and then there's a
question calling a cab we're in DC right
now calling cab is very easy where I
come from Orange County I don't know if
there are kind of companies I'm sure
there are but no one I knew had their
number handy so which is not and i'm not
actually even saying you're wrong it
made of that you're right right just it
seemed to me that was a little bit loose
given the seriousness of the topic let's
go back through some so one day I'd love
about your question is it shows that
you're really thinking about what we're
doing and the whole point of our book is
to get people thinking we we don't have
happy right every time we want to I mean
we are right every time I look
absolutely right every time and people
are so it's were wrong but so let's just
think about the kinds of a some so
obviously we wouldn't have put it in
there if we thought we were wrong okay
so when we first started thinking about
we went to the data with that well there
must be good data on how much people
walk okay period not drunk so it's hard
to even figure out how much people walk
and actually a half mile we send people
walk a half mile a day and it's actually
that's probably you know a long roads
and that's probably a gross exaggeration
of how much people walk I think people
probably walk even less than that and
then the question of how much of it when
they walk when they're drunk well again
it who knows I mean it's hard to find
the data so you look we look at time you
surveys try to look at everything we
could and it's just not exactly clear
and so that's where we say well let's
take this assumption of one in 140 and
then at least people can think about it
what I always think it's important when
you're coming up with a explaining idea
is to put the assumptions number one
of people but also to explain them in
ways they can get some intuition for
them all right so by saying we think the
same proportion of miles that are driven
drunk or walk drunk okay you can think
about that well my own life I'm a big
drunk walk or maybe you know and I think
so maybe that's wrong all right you know
in my you know I haven't win a pro yet
i'm still at ya so i think that you know
so let's take so let's secure the
particular point you raised which are
really good one so you know so is it
true that maybe the people who are
walking drunk hour on average much
drunker than the people who are driving
drunk and that would skew our numbers
are saying that if the exact same person
with exact same amount of drunkenness
switched from walking to driving then
the the benefits would be you know what
the difference would be a lot less than
we say okay and that's possible so again
you go to the data and you might think
well of course there must be really good
data on the said the US government keeps
every fatal crash now turns out they
don't very often do the blood alcohols
on the on the pedestrians because
there's nothing illegal about walking
drunk and so you can't really find it a
but i think you're probably right i
think to the very limited amount of data
we have the people who are walking drunk
i'll have it I do have higher blood
alcohols and the people who are who are
driving drunk okay so that works in one
direction towards maybe making the 821
an overstatement on the other hand if
you look at say where people are driving
don't you probably think there is a lot
of drunk walk and going around in rural
areas I mean no you can't really walk 20
miles home or 50 ml something turns out
driving drunk in rural areas much more
dangerous over twice as dangerous as
driving drunk and urban areas so you
just you know you fall asleep at the
wheel you go faster and so that works in
the opposite direction because probably
a lot of the walkers are are going to be
in the urban settings we're driving
drunk isn't as dangerous whereas the
drivers will be in the real thing so hey
I think we don't know the exact answer
but no one does I mean it's not it so
we're talking about being experts in our
expert but you look in the literature
and this is no research on drunk walking
and I actually truly believe I think the
data supported the drunk walking is far
far more dangerous than drunk driving
now I would expect that groups like mad
or sad might embrace this and say while
we're trying to save people's lives and
we've been doing it through drunk
driving but maybe there's more maybe
maybe we have to expand our agenda to
try to
to take this now I'm guessing that your
intuition for this is better than my
hope which is that the reaction of mad
and sad isn't going to be oh this is
great we have a whole new agenda a whole
new way to save up to a thousand you
know 5,000 pedestrians killed every year
walking drunk I hope that they we have
but I kind of doubt I think that's the
point I mean there are a thousand people
every year out of the out of the 13,000
people who are killed in alcohol-related
accidents every year 1000 those are
pedestrians I London who are drunk right
I find it hard to believe that the
parents or siblings or whatever those
people don't want to know this they
wouldn't I find hard to believe that
they wouldn't want to know this fact
beforehand so you're right if you want
to think in a very limited way like holy
cow are these guys saying you know
you're drunk at a friend's party or my
way you should just get in and drive
home instead because it's safer to you
know we don't say that and I would hope
that no one in the right mind would
recommend that i think it's an ad and
look what's ironic about this also i
don't know if it's caused much
controversy other than you i don't think
it actually actually thought of it in
that way before so i think that's that's
great but i think that if the notion is
that there's a something that can be
done beyond what people are you thinking
about as a safety measure great the
irony is that for us we're usually the
last people to be fear mongers in fact
we spent a lot of the first book talking
about all the things that people were
scared of all out of proportion to the
actual risk this is probably one case
that i can think of where we actually
say here's something that we actually
don't think about very often but it's
but it's worth thinking about so i would
hate to think that one person would draw
also like I don't know California I've
never lived in California but I think
there are more options than not walking
or driving drunk you can stay somewhere
if it if you can't get a cab you can
find somebody else to drive you so it's
not in any way an endorsement of doing
anything other than not walking drunk
because a thousand people die every year
doing it but I wish I a little if you
had a gun to your head and you had
exactly two choices should you drive
drunk or should you walked off I think
the answer is you should drive dunk I
mean people don't like that there were a
few cases where you have a gun to your
head and someone is forcing you to do
one of those two things ah but I think
that is the
that is the right interpretation right
so and so that was my interpretation of
as well as I appreciate you backing up
and I guess I use it in a similar way
that you guys used it actually right
which is to sort of illustrate something
a lot of the conclusions in the book are
very surprising i think what our
exchange are a moment ago showed at
least in that one I think that one maybe
more than some of the others but there's
a lot of uncertainty in that estimate
right as you said some things point in
one direction something putting another
but your main points that we don't
really have great data but if we don't
great that it actually makes a
conclusion hard and what wasn't present
I thought as much as what my hope was
uncertainty right that these are tricky
questions and coming to them with a new
set of eyes can answer them in ways
maybe people didn't expect but maybe
those answers to our wrong just as the
current consensus is and what was
interesting about superfreakonomics as
opposed to your your previous effort was
it as you said at the beginning it took
on much bigger questions and so the
amount of controversy which hasn't
primarily been on trunk walking with
drunk driving but on other pieces will
talk about later has been significant
for that reason because and so I'm just
curious on the on the drunk driving
piece of it see you are comfortable with
that condition I mean kids I hate to say
I look at that the same way a lot of
things we looked at which there is
uncertainty but it's not like we're
saying that drunk walking is three
percent more dangerous than drunk
driving or fifteen percent or twenty
percent or a hundred percent or two
hundred percent or 504 resent I mean for
you it's eight hundred percent right so
there's so much room for slippage I mean
the kinds of assumptions you would have
to make to get back to you know the
better choice personal choice is to is
to walk than to drive really i think is
quite extreme and i think is almost no
way you could cook up data or
assumptions that would make it happen i
mean what you say you say that we didn't
give him this in the first book what we
did I mean we had the question of a
swimming pool versus a god right and so
you know that that got a lot of people
upset when we made the claim that if you
have a swimming pool in your house and
you have a gun in your house the
swimming pool is much more likely to
kill your child than the gun and that's
actually very similar in the way the
arguments are structured the same kinds
of assumptions I think the abortion and
crime stuff it's also had the same kind
of feel where there was some uncertainty
about it but you know the effects were
big and and and we do I'm
it's a popular book right so we can
we're not there aren't you know endless
footnotes where we describe the exact
ways but we try to lay out the
assumptions and we try to kind of mix a
way of telling your story we talk about
what some of the concerns are I mean
we're very sent to the idea that you
can't just kind of I mean what we don't
like is people who go out and like say
that they're right about something and
never give you know any any attention
all to what some of the shortcomings
might be whatever but we always tried it
I mean maybe out is my greatest would
like us to look ironically one of the
you know one of the segments of the book
that that a lot of people not a lot of
people but a few really noisy people are
very upset about as a way that we treat
global warming which we talk about later
and ironically the point there is we're
introducing the great degree of
uncertainty in climate scenarios which
to me is one of the key parts of that so
we actually I think we do try to
acknowledge uncertainty as much as we
can because it is a big piece of look
what's interesting is you you're right
you can interpret our drunk walking
finding in any one of any number of ways
but the point of that and the point of
almost everything else in the book is to
give a reader some thoughts or some
information to try to think about the
world and think about make different
decisions one big piece of one big
reason why making decisions is really
hard and this is what fueled the field
of behavioral economics the work of
Danny Kahneman and Amos Tversky it was
this very breakthrough research on
uncertainty what it does to people right
so if you have uncertainty in an
equation it changes everything about it
and climate science is such a
fascinating complex topic now again
we're not climate signed scientists one
argument would be you know let's we'll
wait on common sense because we got to
take a break right now we'll get to it
when we get back but we'll be back in a
moment with the Steven Levitan stephen
dubner authors of superfreakonomics
afterwards and several other c-span
programs are available for download as
podcasts more with stephen dubner and
steven levitt in just a moment did you
know you can view book TV programs
online go to book TV org type the name
of the author book or subject into the
search area in the upper left hand
corner of the page select the watch link
now you can view the entire program you
might also explore the recently on book
TV box or the featured programs box to
find and view recent and featured
programs afterwards with stephen dubner
and steven levitt continues I'm Ezra
Klein and we're back with stephen dubner
and steven levitt authors of
superfreakonomics before i went to break
we began getting a little bit into the
most controversial section of the book
which is the piece on global warming and
our listeners are probably heard about
cap and trade and we'll hear about
carbon taxes but the book advocates a
different solution which is using new
technologies to re-engineer or to
engineer to manipulate the very climate
of the earth which back back when I was
a kid would get you a quick visit from
the Justice League but here you're
saying it's the answer so what what
convinced you I think everyone would
answer to what okay I feel really clear
about what what we think okay the
question we try to answer is if we
decided the earth was way too hot just
too hot and we wanted to cool it down
quickly how should we go about doing it
okay that's the question that we really
I think answer quite effectively in the
blog they're all sorts of other
questions you might want to answer like
what kind of legacy do we want to leave
for our children is it wrong for
humankind to leave its imprint on
society now that's those are questions
that we're not good I don't know if
we've stressed it in this interview are
not enough that the morality is not you
know ethics are not what we know
anything about what we try to do is take
an economic view and will meld that into
whatever question we answer so just it's
going to be really careful that that I
think on the facts we actually have very
few disagreements with our critics
in the environmental domain it's really
just a question of what you know we're
trying to answer a different question
then they have because I do not think
that actually first and foremost the
idea of cap and trade or radical
reactions and carbon emissions are our
first I mean I don't think any of them
would agree that that is the right
answer the question if you wanted to
cool down the earth in a hurry is that
how you would do it well so the well why
don't we tell me first before we get
into it tell me a little bit about the
geoengineering solutions in a very
tangible way right how would they wore
sure so geoengineering is a word that's
been applied to a number of ideas that
basically say yeah intentionally using
engineering to change the the way the
the way the planet is kind of working so
if you think about it in a organic way
we've RDG we've been geoengineering the
living daylights out of the earth for
the past hundred years unintentionally
unintel that's intention intentionally
but without purpose yeah without without
the idea of making things better except
for our economies and our societies
right so that's the point so in the
space but let's say two hundred years
will probably burn through about three
hundred million years worth of
accumulated fossil fuels right that's
Geoengineer the earth by contributing a
whole lot of things the environment that
weren't there before so the idea is well
if the problem is really bad bad enough
to worry about in other words if the
central problem is Leavitt just said a
few minutes ago is warming and there are
other problems to discuss and we discuss
some of those but if the central problem
is warming is stopping burning the
fossil fuels even at a very accelerated
rate rate one that may be just a dream
to achieve with any kind of political
friction at all is that sufficient and
the answer as best as we can tell is
probably not and the reason why is it
carbon mitigation as a kind of primary
route even if it could be achieved far
more successfully than there's any
indication that it could be would
probably be too little and too late and
too optimistic to achieve that goal now
there are a lot of other reasons why you
might want to burn fewer fossil fuels
you might want to find cheaper and
cleaner and better forms of energy I
think almost everybody is in favor of
that except you know maybe a few very
interested parties ocean acidification
is
real issue the geoengineering in and of
itself would not address but if the idea
is to cool the earth if it becomes
dangerously hot what can you do because
atmospheric carbon dioxide has a
half-life of a hundred years so what's
there is there and will stay there and
will probably keep contributing to it so
the ideas of Jew engineering range from
the very environmentally friendly
sounding ones like creating higher
albedo high den more reflective oceanic
clouds clouds do a very good job of
cooling the earth to some they do that
how would they cool the earth more know
how do you how do they create a cloud so
one idea it's a again as kind of non low
friction as you could imagine it's by
using this fleet of boats that don't
even have engines that have kind of
turbines underwater that are driven by
wave power and it would literally kick
up salt spray one of the reasons why
clouds over the ocean are not as
reflective as one might like them too if
you're trying to cool the earth is that
there aren't as many cloud condensation
nuclei I'm we probably don't want to
turn into a sciences but but the science
is fascinating again we're not climate
scientists but we tried to learn as much
as we could about it cloud condensation
nuclei are cloud condensation nuclei are
sparser over the water than over land
where you have a lot of dust and so on
so the idea this is generated by his
clouds to build themselves around choose
to build themselves around and to make
themselves denser the more dense they
are generally the more reflective they
are the more reflective they are the
more sunlight they reflect the less heat
reaches here and oceans are dark their
dark McCullar serves your blocks of heat
lots of sunlight they absorb so the more
you light stuff that's some of the
sunlight bounces back out and doesn't
heat there's like so generally you want
stuff it light you don't want to surf
this dark kind of first end clouds are
puffy and nice and reflective and you
could do a good job of cooling near then
there's a radically different sounding
solution that is easily the most kind of
frightening sounding at first and but
will surely be one of the most
controversial ones which is using sulfur
dioxide a kind of a targeted application
of sulfur dioxide sprayed into the
stratosphere which kind of forms the
strata shield a cooling shield here's
this is based on nature as well in 1991
there was a volcanic explosion mount
pinatubo in the Philippines and it was
the biggest volcanic explosion about a
hundred years in terms of sulfur dioxide
stratosphere and what happens when
sulphur dioxide gets into the
stratosphere at that height most
volcanoes are exploding all the time and
putting their effluvia lower into the
troposphere when it gets to that height
it behaves differently and it mixes with
the aerosol there and kind of forms this
vapor layer around the planet that is
this kind of stratospheric shield in the
aftermath of Mount Pinatubo global
ground temperatures decreased by a
little over one degree Fahrenheit for
about two years it was a huge change in
global temperature as a result of this
volcano what there's some scientists who
we write about in superfreakonomics want
to do is essentially mimic nature or
recreate that kind of explosion out you
could run around dynamiting volcanoes
and that would be really disastrous and
messy and horribly inefficient because
it puts hundreds of millions of tons of
junk in the air that you mostly don't
want there instead they'd like to do a
kind of targeted garden hose to the sky
where you then spritz sulfur dioxide in
a very relatively very very small amount
that would be enough to mimic what
Pinatubo Dutton does and and and
essentially form a shield to cool the
earth now it sounds absurd it sounds
like science fiction it sounds like
there's all kinds of dangers involved
one of the reasons why this proposals
being seriously considered is because
the nature proof does exist from a
volcano in other words sulfur dioxide
natural experiment in other words a very
natural experiment right now again
there's a lot of elements of this to
talk about and what we're advocating is
that this kind of solution be considered
be put on the table in addition to
carbon mitigation ideas because if the
problem is bad enough to worry about a
lot which we think it is then you should
look for a solution that we think will
work to cool the earth rather than just
gradually cut down on carbon emissions
and I think a key thing about this
either of the two schemes that done we
just described the putting the clouds
over the ocean or the sulfur dioxides
strata shield is that they're completely
reversible and you can build them today
right so they could have within a year
or two we could have these these systems
up and running and we will get immediate
feedback and whether they cooled the
earth as a poster that even if we were
to you know cut or stabilizer cut our
car
emissions would be 30 to 50 years before
we started to feel the effects it seems
to me like if you if you thought about
this differently and you just said there
are two ways to solve some problem of
the earth getting quarter hotter you can
either spend a trillion dollars and I
think that people don't talk about when
they talk about this carbon mitigation
is how incredibly expensive to our
economy these this carbon mitigation
will be I mean the best estimates are
two percent of our gdp will be spent
every year for the foreseeable future
cutting carbon okay now it may be that
you just want to cut carbon right that
there are moral reasons why you think
that putting a lot of carbon into the
air is really really bad it's just the
wrong thing to do okay but if you really
the primary reason is you want to keep
the earth cool I think we have better
solutions to keep an earth cool and
that's what I say when I think you can
ask different questions right it's a
band-aid right putting sulfur dioxide
making more clock to their band aids if
you keep on putting carbon in the air
there'll be more and more pressure to
keep keep the world you know did you
make the water but on the other hand I
think it's wrong to think about carbon
dioxide as a poison carbon dioxide is
not carbon monoxide it is not
necessarily a pollutant in the same
sense in fact there's there's evidence
from environmentalists it shows that
when you have more carbon dioxide in the
air plants grow better right so in
greenhouses I actually inject a lot of
carbon dioxide into the air of the
greenhouse because the plants will grow
faster so it's I think we've kind of got
into this mythology that carbon is a bad
bad bad i mean garmin does make the
planet hotter but if it didn't do that
I'm even Ken caldera you know who was
someone who who who wants to get a total
ban on carbon climate scientist climate
scientist yeah once a total ban on
carbon says that all else equal we'd
rather have carbon more carbon in the
air than less it's just that it's a
change that is that Betty's problem and
I think the other important thing to
raise its two possible reactions to
let's say there was a strata she'll put
up against all odds because it's hard to
me I mean what's interesting is there
will be congressional hearings in a few
days actually on geoengineering and it's
fascinating to see this part of climate
science having having getting a little
spotlight because we think it's very
much worth considering at least but if
you think about two of the
possible reactions to let's say a
stratus yield the the real downside
would be that it creates what you'd call
an excuse to pollute right everybody
would say oh well they're cooling the
earth so boom barrel ahead and do
exactly what you've been doing without
acknowledging what the other
consequences of that might be that's the
down that's a potential really big
downside the potential really big upside
is it buys you time in other words if
warming is the problem that you're
trying to solve right now and if all
these other issues mostly energy issues
how do we make clean energy not just for
7 billion people but it might be 10
billion people if we need to do that
could we use some more time well it
seems the case because we're not there
yet so if that's the case if you've got
a geoengineering solution that could
keep the earth managed at a manageable
temperature again as ken caldera climate
scientists that we write about it at
some length he makes the point that
there is no magic temperature for the
earth there is no magic carbon dioxide
level there is no magic sea level it's
changed many times in many directions in
it in a couple directions over the
course of the of our planet what you do
want to avoid is rapid change because
rapid change is generally catastrophic
change so if the danger is rapid change
and the rapid changes in the form of
temperature change then it would be
great to have you know one way to think
of it is when you build a house you try
to everything you tend can never to have
a fire in that house and it's one of the
great marks of progress of the 21st
century we've gotten much better at
stopping fires from devastating cities
and so on you try to do everything you
can to stop a fire but you also want to
have a sprinkler system we hope that the
house is not burning down but if there's
even a one-percent chance that the house
is burning down you want a sprinkler
system in the house and that's one thing
that I think brings up so we talked
about ken caldera and this is you know
very it's very controversial solution
among climate scientists and so for one
of the reasons actually you just brought
up you could imagine a scenario in which
we know that carbon dioxide is warming
the earth so we just know that and you
create sort of this shield made of made
of the part of sulfate particles and
china's sort of says ha that was a close
one fire up some more coal plants and
for time where you end up having
situation in which humans have to do
more and more and
more manipulation of the of the
planetary climate in order to handle
what is as we know to be with carbon and
accelerating build-up of an element with
very very very long half life until
death and so if you have that scenario
happen you do end up in a situation now
I wanted something from the beginning of
your book here where you talked about a
sort of the vision of freakonomics right
which is it the one of the most powerful
laws in the universe is the law of
unintended consequences and so a lot of
these scientists what they would say to
you and what I've read them right in
response here is that they're just it
isn't that doesn't sort of work in
theory but it's very dangerous to do
this so we've had sort of to some degree
a natural experiment to with carbon
dioxide we know in this more of it the
earth gets hotter less of it it would
cool down a little bit with the volcanic
ash we've talked about that actually
went away after a couple of years and we
don't know what would happen if we just
sort of had to keep belching sulfate
particles into into the atmosphere sort
of firm a fairly undetermined or
potentially for everyone I think the
matrix had one mission of this it wasn't
the right vision but it was bad to
scorch the skies back then and so you
just end up with a situation early in
the book one of the things you argues
that we should be very modest and how we
look at this that we should be very very
careful because a lot of things we think
to be true that seemed to work in theory
don't work in practice but on this you
know we've only got one earth mm-hmm and
it seems a big it seems a fairly big
risk right but it's a risk it's a recent
bigger to ignore these things and watch
the earth heat up and you know
cataclysmic things like ice shelves to
melt and say damn I really wish I really
wish we lived in the Nathan Myhrvold who
had this idea that could have kept the
earth cold well you know while we figure
out other ways to put carbon a yeah I
mean I think ultimately yeah here's my
belief my belief is that and we haven't
talked about that these geoengineering
solutions are unbelievably cheap by
itself for for less than the cost of Al
Gore's last big ad campaign they could
build either of the two geo engineering
solutions we just described and stay
likely stabilize the temperature of
their now it might be just a band-aid
right so I meant saying it'd be a primal
solution but at least it could give us a
time that governor talked about hey but
what I think is
not been discussed much is that
technology has gotten up out of many
jams in the past ones that we never
thought we could solve the problem
seemed impossible and then suddenly we
tell them the amount of effort that has
gone into issues of geoengineering of
safe getting getting carbon out of the
air I mean there's every reason to be
confident that as time goes by we will
think think of cheaper and better ways
to get carbon out of the air once we put
it there okay and maybe that's a false
maybe we never will maybe we'll be left
in the situation but but to say that
this is a license to pollute I think you
gotta remember two things it's not that
clear that it's pollution if the if the
earth is warming I think that was
licensed to emit carbon diox-- exactly
okay so but the cost of admitting carbon
dioxide goes down radically which is
exactly why people think they're going
to do more of it right but but for the
same logic you would say we should never
allow people have seatbelts in their
cars right because once you put a
seatbelt in the car well now if I get in
a crash I'm less likely to die I'm going
to drive more recklessly like we still
think that it makes sense to allow you
know did to take steps that reduce the
damage from the action we take so we
don't say you know we should not allow
doctors to work on on you know solutions
to diabetes that's just that just gives
people a license to get overweight right
and if as long as we reduce the
consequence of being overweight people
going to be overweight more I mean it's
a tricky argument if you believe it
should be done in concert with things
like cabin trade and carbon taxes or do
you believe that it should be a
replacement for them so I'm let me see
I'm probably extremely but my viewers at
the current time the cost of carbon
medication is really really expensive
and so I think if you took a year or two
we're learning a lot we're learning a
lot about these issues by years by
decades if we if we we we greatly
restrict carbon today we will feel the
benefits in 50 years if we greatly
restrict carbon in three years we will
see the benefits in 53 years I think
with the amount we learn in the next
three years I'd rather wait on carbon if
we have other ways to control the
temperature of the earth because it
really is in the short run the thing
we're worried about temperature of the
earth okay there are other things that
are important like ocean acidification
things that are on a a much longer time
table so but but I will be clear and say
that this is an opinion in mind that
that most of what we try to do in here
is based on a mix of science and
economics I think this
kind of this is a little further afield
it is really an opinion that's informed
by the economics and porn bioscience and
I think the economics has not gotten
nearly enough enough part of this debate
that you can't just think about benefits
you've got to think about the cost of
this mitigation and it is incredibly
expensive now we used to think a
trillion dollars a lot maybe with the
bailout we don't think so much about
anymore but we're not a ton of money so
let me pretend to be as right for one
second if you do if i can borrow your
brain for one minute so is this another
case of economic imperialism is this
another case where the economist's are
coming in and saying oh climate science
we think we can be helpful there we
think we can apply models and a set of
theory of thinking about the problem in
a way that can improve upon the current
thinking and if so how and why I think
we take as an account of sight take is
given the knowledge the climate
scientists have generated and what I try
to do is to put that together with what
we know in economics about what you do
when things are very uncertain right
where things that economist know about
it about decision making under
uncertainty and you think about the cost
side and the benefit side the value of
waiting the option day I mean one of the
important contributions of economic
thinking last 20 years you're thinking
about option value and how the value of
waiting and the ability to wait is
incredibly incredibly valuable so I
think there is a role in this debate for
economists that hasn't been prominent
enough do I think that a comment should
determine the debate absolutely not
among other things Economist's are
completely dependent upon the climate
scientist to do the science department
okay but on the same time I think the
climate scientists have not been
respecting very much the economics of it
the climate scientists are really often
operating under the idea that there's a
kind of a combination of science and
what's right or what is moral and
they've been using those two pieces of a
pedestal but there's really this
economic piece that's been left out
among other things there in other sizes
last question on climb before we move on
to some other things but there are two
implications overcame my one is it
economists are in sort of agreement on
this which insofar as the discipline
sort of has a consensus position my
understand which is more towards things
like taxes which a lot of them are more
comfortable frankly than geoengineering
where they haven't done a lot of work on
it
but number two as well isn't the these
are what the climate scientist would say
to you is it the big argument here is
time that we gain a lot from having a
couple x three years but in fact we
don't have those years because what
carbon does is it builds up and then it
remains it's a big point you make in
your book that there's a half-life of
carbon that is incredibly long if you
let it get to that concentration then we
are in a situation with the Geoengineer
forever whatever you know whether we
like it or not and if we let go of the
politics now they don't move forward so
what is the risk to of waiting right not
very much because it stays for so long
the risk of one more year of waiting is
actually really small we've already
essentially waited for 50 years so the
difference between waiting 50 years and
51 years isn't that big it's it's it's
exactly the kind of situation we're
waiting right you've already got a huge
stock in the air so the flow relative of
the stock is very small okay and then
the benefits come way far away right
earlier i should say i'm sorry the costs
come way far away the cost of having put
too much and so you know the difference
when you think about the difference in
what you'd pay to you know have the
earth have a little bit less carbon
dioxide 51 years from now versus 52
years from now I mean you just wouldn't
pay that much it's it's so I really
think that the economics of it which are
surprising which catch people off-guard
really do say that what you want to do
now is you want to take the steps that
will give you that are cheap and that
will allow you to get information about
the likely global catastrophe as quickly
as possible and then if you learn that
we are heading for global catastrophe
then of course you pull out all the
stops right so then then you say like if
we wait three years and we realize
things are much worse than we thought
okay we'll leave the shield on that's
great we'll leave the show like a that's
keeping us cool but we have to basically
cut carbon completely out of a
production completely okay then then we
even really cost the same thing right
because if we're going to cut carbon out
completely in three years well a few
more years of flow on kind of matter
that much so I think I think it's um I
think these are tricky questions to
think about but if you actually start
writing down the models I think that you
are unless you really think there's a
very high chance of global cash 3v
soon you don't you gotta feel nervous
when you when you have two options right
if you have no other options with no
other options then if you gotta think
hard about the expensive one but when
you have other options that buy you time
it does I mean in some sense it gives
you a little bit of a license balut in
the short run so you can figure out
whether or not the pollution you're
putting out how costly it is because the
hard thing about the carbon tax is
what's the task how big should it be
what is it cost I mean we have no idea
of the cost if we know that there's
going to be the end of humanity in 100
years well then the text should be very
big right if we if it's just going to be
that there's a one-in-a-million chance
of the end of humanity on hundred years
then the text should be smaller and
nobody knows what that tax should be and
the politics are going to be where we
sort out that text I think there's no
guarantee whatsoever that we get the
right tax at all but I think the longer
we wait the better chance we have
getting my texts and so for the final
two questions I'm going to sort of
create the freakonomics advice corner if
you don't mind and and on two issues one
one sort of small on one quite quite
large so you have a fascinating chapter
on the economics of prostitution and
much of it focuses on on Allie who's a
frico of freakonomics blog reader who
got in touch with you as I understand it
and and I sort of uh I guess would call
a high-class prostitute who she's made
for fair amount of money and things
actually you know for her turn out
pretty well now she's in an economics
course at a university somewhere and so
on so my question is if the 18 year old
daughter of a friend called you and said
I'm considering following her example
what advice would you have for her yeah
I don't want my daughter to be a
prostitute but I think that it's a I
think that it's a quintessential
weakness of societal dialogue when we
can appreciate that our preferences are
not other people's preferences even if
the the number of women who would want
to lead the life that Ally Leeds is one
in a hundred thousand and even though
it's illegal it doesn't mean that people
like us can't look at this case and try
to write about and try to learn
something from it so I think that's one
thing that's really interesting
especially about being in this town
where policy is almost this almost a
zero-sum game but preferences become to
be seen as a zero-sum game the mind if
yours are yours they cannot
mine and with that we kind of lose sight
of the fact that people really do
believe and prefer an act differently
it's what makes politics often so ugly
you cannot conceive how a guy like him
could think that way because it's so far
from your preferences so my preference
set and my preference set for my
daughter would be very very different
from Ali's but that doesn't mean that
there isn't something in there that's
enlightening and it's also in line with
what we do often which is it's not a
judgment we're making it's not about you
know this is good this is bad this is
right this is wrong this is this is what
is and whether you just want to observe
the world or like a lot of people in DC
want to fix the world or change the
world in some way i think the essential
foundation fermented to know what's
going on in the world first so if you
know that a woman like ali can make five
hundred dollars an hour that's that's a
strong insight into understanding why
someone like that will do that well
actually assuming that I would actually
legalize prostitution if able I actually
agree with you and I'm not suggesting
with the preference here should be that
people shouldn't go into it what I'm
saying is what did the chapter teach you
right what did he teach you about the
economics of prostitution if somebody
did want to go into that field because
as you say you went in and learn a lot
about it and that's an area we don't
have a lot of data and the data set is
very interesting I think one thing is
that if you are high and prosecute the
last thing you want is prostitution
legalized because I mean the reason I
elegance paid so much is because she's
figured out how to get through the
barriers to entry to being a charge
tomorrow exactly and she knows that her
weight would go way way down if
everything she says she didn't she
wouldn't want it to be legalized I mean
I think the other thing what you learn i
think i learned from doing the study
actually think the study of the street
prosecutors of all the strides ever done
might have been the one that i learned
the most from was just it is such a
window and how the inner city works and
you know things you would never imagine
like the fact that in chicago a
prostitute of street prostitutes is more
likely to have sex with a police officer
than to be arrested by a police officer
I mean it's just over and over on all
these different dimension that was
shocked by the things that we we
discovered and I think in some sense it
starts to give you some insight not just
into prostitution about in dec maybe
poke policy more generally and what you
might try to do
with with inner cities and so and then
to move from the individual over to the
macro you have a couple actually
terrific chapters in there about health
care and in particular sort of very
uncommon datasets into that a couple
miles away here is where we're trying to
fix something in Washington we're doing
health care forum yeah but now imagine
you didn't have to pass it through
Congress you didn't have to try to get
the votes Max Baucus and everything else
what did your dad I'll lead you to
believe about how we should fix a health
care system yeah you know well I
all-star I mean I I think I think not
that much and it's pretty I think the
the data that i have that we've looked
at on health care are on very specific
parts of the problem and i don't think
they are quite right to inform a big
debate now I'll tell you what economist
would say not based on data but I'm
theory is that health care is a market
where there's a huge disconnect between
the people who are paying and the
choices that are made right so when I go
to the store and i want to buy oranges
or apples I you know they cost me fifty
cents on the margin I decide how many /
a car I pay for it I think that
ultimately if we want to rationalize the
health care system the stronger we can
make connections between what people are
buying and what they're paying for that
thing is is going to be the answer now
that's number one not a politically very
very viable entering number two what it
really it competes with the insurance
component of of health care right you if
you pay on the margin then you don't
have insurance so they would ultimately
economist inanimate saying you should
let the economist run the world I think
would be a disaster if you did but but
what an economist health care system
would be one work we had insurance
against catastrophic things but that
more or less people paid on the margin
for the health care as they went it
would be the politically the least
popular kind of setup you could ever
have but I think we would have more
rational decisions at least yeah if we
have a min i'll add one thing to that
one story that we write about in the
book is about one commodity that's
always in short supply in health care
which is information so we tell the
story of a fellow two fellows Craig Fiat
and Mark Smith at Washington Hospital
Center who realized that this scarcity
was really damaging it was damaging not
just to people's health but to cost
hugely so they decided that the best way
to actually improve care
cut costs was by harnessing information
gathering it better storing it better
analyzing it better and using it better
both in a treatment and a financial
sense and the good news is that their
system has caught on as being
distributed because what we see is that
cost savings that come from just very
very very simple fixes like manipulating
and handling information better can go a
long way to providing better better
treatment alway medically n financially